in the last video we saw that China had
increased its m1 money supply from
November of 2009 to November of 2010 by
roughly 700 billion dollars what I want
to do in this video is compare that to
its increase in foreign assets so if we
move up here and once again all of this
data is straight from the website of the
People's Bank of China and this is the
URL right over here and so you could get
it from multiple years and actually have
a ton of other statistics and so this
chart tells us there are foreign assets
and foreign exchange and I'm actually
gonna focus on foreign assets because
when they print currency and says they
say with their printed when they go by
dollars with that dollars they could buy
well they could keep it in dollars they
could buy Treasury bonds or they could
just go buy US assets so you so assets
are the best are the best measure of
what they're holding that is denominated
in other currencies so let's look at
their growth from November of 2009 to
November of 2010 and this is why I
picked November because we didn't have
December of 2010 in this chart so
foreign assets and once again this is in
a hundred million UN foreign assets in
November 2009 183 thousand six hundred
fifty one and that's in hundred million
UN and then you fast forward to November
2010 it is two hundred and twelve
thousand seven hundred thirty three so
let's let's once again put that in terms
that make a little bit more sense at
least for someone who's used to dollars
so when I used a very rough
approximation for the u.s. UN exchange
rate in the last minutes actually closer
to six point five eight now but it gets
us to about 700 billion dollars increase
in money supply that we got in the last
video now let's check this out so we end
up at two hundred and twelve thousand
seven hundred and thirty three hundred
million when in foreign assets November
2010 - 183 183 thousand six hundred and
fifty-one so that's the difference now
this is in hundred million un so let's
multiply by a hundred and so this will
be in million un now if we divide this
by a thousand this will give us a
billion when
billion when so it's actually close to
its two thousand nine hundred billion UN
so it's almost three trillion UN and if
we want to convert this into dollars
I'll just use the same six point five I
could use six point five eight now let
me just do six point five eight so
divided by six point five eight to put
it into billions of US dollars so you
see that there's a 440 440 billion
increase in foreign assets when
denominated in dollars so let's think
about that so let's think about this m1
so from November November 2009 to
November November 2010 m1 m1 was up by
approximately seven hundred billion
seven hundred billion dollars and
foreign assets foreign assets were up by
approximately what was that number that
I just had there approximately four
hundred and forty billion four hundred
and forty billion so most of the
expansion of their monetary base of
their m1 base was to go out and buy
foreign assets over the course of 2010
and the balance is really just to kind
of support the growth of the actual
Chinese economy but most of it is to go
out there buy foreign assets in other
and other currencies and actually help
keep the UN devalued this is some on
Khan of the Khan Academy for CNBC